demain a founding la wwe lance son grand
tournoi censé dénicher sa prochaine
super star tu vas être hors par baboo
champions c'est l'heure de jeu le but il
est déjà élevé on dirait que les halls
minus veut devenir une superstar du cash
et en titres
tu t'en tireras pas comme ça comme ça
bon les pouvoirs de ce masque ne se
révèle que si la personne qui le porte
mérine sa magie non non non non
et s'est passé quoi là
quand j'enfile ce masque c'est comme si
je devienne une véritable superstar
oh je fais trop faire le portrait je
vous conseille de les lâcher maintenant
j'avais jamais rien vu d'aussi cool amis
de la wwe
nous allons vous offrir une chance
d'intégrer la nxt et de devenir une
véritable superstar
oui blanc qui voit l'équipe l'équipe en
est qui connaît ce gala va affronter ce
géo je vais te mettre ko mon pote
[Applaudissements]
o le combat vient de commencer comment
ça se fait que tu es déjà trempé veut
vraiment que je réponde à cette question
au dernier finaliste du temps
puisque je croyais je plaisante je vous
souhaite surtout pas bonne
les pouvoirs de ce masque ce n'est pas
ça qui transporte la vraie force
elle vient de là et de la croyable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faites du bruit pour notre ami sans son
ton
bienvenue à notre grande finale wood
avait vraiment enfin est-ce que tout va
bien bouger pas mal de calories ces
derniers temps